what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have a lot of information
coming directly from Marvel Studios with
a lot of it coming from Marvel Studios
president Kevin feige and the other part
coming from Marvel Studios as vice
president Nate Moore so the source for
this info is as good as it gets and it's
really interesting recently they have
been talking about in interviews their
process of one leaks how they are trying
to contain leaks a little bit more and
two how they are striving to get better
how they are trying to make better
movies better shows and they talk about
what their main goal is always with
every movie and every show what the goal
is of Marvel Studios now a lot of people
are really excited for phase five we
know that Marvel Studios is going to
kick it up a notch with phase five
they've already said that we already
know that phase four was kind of a cool
down period a little bit of a break we
got introduced to some new characters
and we had a lot of stories about some
previous characters that have been
around for a little bit it but there
were a lot of people who thought it was
kind of slow and thought that the
connectivity just really wasn't there
but Marvel Studios has addressed this
and said that moving forward with phase
five it's about to be completely
different in fact they literally said
that those characters that were
introduced and that had stories in phase
four are now about to be thrown into the
fire and that everything is really going
to start to connect and we're going to
see all the dots connect really soon and
how in phase four it was just a big
setup for phase five phase six and
Secret Wars and you might have heard the
rumor that Kevin feige wasn't exactly
pleased with phase four but we know that
they are always trying to improve and
now Vice President Nate Moore along with
Kevin feige have sort of told us their
process on how they try to improve with
each project so they're basically
telling us how they are going to improve
upon phase four and make Phase 5 and
phase six even better and they even talk
about trying to keep leaks from getting
out now I know a lot of people who watch
my channel love leaks love spoilers I do
too but the speculation and not knowing
and what is real and what is not real is
really the fun part so what Marvel
Studios is talking about is actual leaks
like how the captions for Ant-Man and
the WASP Quantum Mania leaked out those
are some pretty big leaks because that
is the whole movie that is essentially
the script so when talking about the
process of getting better vice president
Nate Moore explains this process and he
states that Disney employees usually get
an email asking do you want to see a
screening however they don't actually
know what the screening is they are
simply asked do you want to see a
screening and here's where it gets kind
of interesting he says and they before
could bring friends now they're not
allowed to because they are cracking
down on leaks and he says I think we
tightened up a bit because frankly
people leak and it sort of ruins it for
everyone but they show up and then we
say we literally have the same guy who
asked the questions his name is Andy
he's fantastic and he goes out front and
he says you're one of the first
audiences to see this pictured movie
Black Panther wakanda forever and
sometimes people are really surprised
and go oh that's one I wanted to see and
sometimes they're really confused like
what's eternals about so these people
really have no idea what movie they're
about to see they just know that it's a
Disney movie where something owned by
Disney so they're cracking down on leaks
but here's where he explains the process
of trying to improve each time and this
is why they have these test screenings
and he says about the amount of people
that come in he says it's small it's not
a 350 360 body screening it's typically
between 80 to 100 people and we do that
three to four times a movie I would say
the only comps we use are our movies so
we can kind of see how it's Fallen
between Iron Man and Captain America you
know what I mean we're not trying to
comp off of creed or speed racer or
things that aren't our movies which is
helpful for us just to see where things
are landing when he says Compu means
comparison basically they are only
comparing Iron Man to movies like
Captain America only MCU movies to other
MCU movies now here he talks about a
division in Marvel Studios called
Parliament he says and then we have an
eternal group who has been called
Parliament for reasons that are too
goofy to get into but it's just all of
us who make these movies and shows and
you get a pretty unvarnished response to
your film that is not motivated by other
than we all want everything to be great
so so far in the process Marvel Studios
shows three to four screenings of 80 to
100 people to just employees people who
don't really have anything to do with
the movie creating the movie that is but
then they show it to their group called
Parliament who are the people that
actually work on the film and are
responsible for making it a good movie
it then explains that they compare the
two groups notes and he says and I think
between those two groups you get an
interesting cross-section of ideas and
you definitely know when both groups are
saying the same thing hey that's a
problem sometimes you'll get more
producer notes versus normal people
notes and you have to decipher which one
is valuable or if they can co-exist but
it is an interesting process and it has
not led us stray so far and the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin feige
went on to address this even further now
Nate Moore's interview was with
deadlines crew call podcast but Kevin
feiges was with the movie business
podcast and when it comes to improving
on projects both TV shows and movies and
improving on phases like phase four this
is what he had to say I think on every
project we worked on we learned lessons
and I think the minute you think you've
learned at all you should probably get
out of the business it's incredible to
say but Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania
which is our next feature that comes out
in February will be our 31st film we've
now completed over 10 series for Disney
plus and the fun thing about starting to
do ongoing narrative long form series
was it was a whole new learning curve so
right there even Kevin feige admits that
this was new there was a learning curve
to doing Disney Plus shows but of course
they are looking to improve they are
always trying to improve and here he
goes on to kind of say how he says and
it was a whole new opportunity to
stretch and work out a different
storytelling muscle for us but I do
think you know and I'm sure an example
will come to me but I do think that on
every project one works on you need to
take your lessons and we do a
post-mortem on every project or at least
we try to if we're not too busy with the
next project to sit and discuss what
went right and what went wrong and he
continues to say and we call them host
mortems now at the time it was a what
went wrong meeting we were asked to do a
what went wrong meaning for Iron Man and
I thought what went wrong this movie's a
giant hit it launched a whole studio why
do we have to do a what went wrong
meeting that's a horrible way to put it
which is what I was reacting to but it
is actually great to sit and go here's
what was done here's how we could have
done it better and we do that on every
project and I guess to distill it down
of what lessons is learned is in
entertain the audience at every turn
Frank Capra has a quote that our
co-president Luis De Esposito quotes
often which is basically distilled down
to entertainment first and this is where
we talk about what Marvel's main goal is
for every project they do movie or show
and this is coming right from the Marvel
Studios president himself entertainment
is first he continues to say you can
have as many beautiful messages and
Beautiful Life theories and beautiful
thematics that you want to put into the
world that all of us do and all of our
filmmakers do but if you are not
entertaining first it will fall on deaf
ears and I think that has always been
the way and that thankfully when you are
making the kind of movies that you love
to see then that will also go into
entertaining yourself which is what we
also try to do here at Marvel Studios so
it's really cool to kind of hear the
process of what goes on in Marvel
Studios when it comes to making things
better and creating things that will
entertain us essentially the fan fans
I've always applauded Marvel Studios
from taking feedback a little bit from
fans of course they can't let fans
dictate what they do but they do listen
and they have multiple screenings to
people who aren't involved with the
project than people who are involved
with the project and then they have
meetings afterwards and look back well
what was done wrong and this is where
they kind of listen to the audience a
little bit as well and they always try
to improve and they've talked about a
big change in Phase five a kind of ramp
up if you will how things are going to
be speeding up essentially so things are
about to get super super exciting but
hey let me know what you thought about
this cool little look into Marvel
studios's process on essentially trying
to become better filmmakers and TV show
producers leave your thoughts down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe stay up to date on all the
latest MCU news you can always follow us
on Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf